today's guest is a one-of-a-kind um
he is a a traveler and a
an adventurer uh in the physical realms
and in the and in the mental realms as
well
you know this is a man that is uh trying
to um
divide himself and conquer uh the
different parts that make us up
as humans he is the number two ranked
bantam uh fighter in the world
uh we are honored to have mr corey san
[Music]
sit hagen tell you my stories
[Applause]
bro from the mountains like you bro
great question
great question death mountain
bro yeah that's
this could be from a questionable
mountain man i didn't think about that
man
they don't really tell you what mountain
this could be from west virginia
this could have illiteracy in it is
that where you're from virginia i'm from
louisiana louisiana
oh yeah yeah that's right yeah man i'm
from down in louisiana man
uh the kid in here today right there
there you go
sugar shawn gave me those oh nice you
had him on too
he came on a while back before he hurt
himself yeah nice
before he got uh
hurting hurting up man he's a cool dude
i met him a couple times
yeah he's a super nice dude he's uh and
now he's a family guy mm-hmm
you know he sprouted that kid out of
nowhere i think
he's got like a gym in his garage and
everything yeah his house does look cool
when you're kind of watching him
it seems like he's on like a uh he's
either in witness protection program but
a really nice place
or he just has like a really cool uh
like domicile you know it's like a
fantasy factory
yeah it seems like he's got some real
space to him yeah um
corey san hagen man dude thanks for
being here yeah man absolutely thank you
very easy dude it's crazy to be around
uh because i feel like when i was a kid
i would be so afraid to be around
somebody that could fight you know
like unless they were my friend like
otherwise it was like fighter dude you
always like
like if you were like in the hall at
school and somebody could fight you
always had to like kind of keep a beam
out of the side of your eye
yeah yeah when you were um in high
school was there like a fight was there
like a kid you remember growing up like
oh that dude can fight
um not really man like
uh i would say that so i grew up in
aurora colorado
which is like uh you know not like a
rough area because it's colorado or
whatever but like as far as colorado
goes it's maybe like one of the more
you know like rougher areas or whatever
but dude i had this friend thomas
johnson
who he was about my size i was really
little growing up too like i was
i was supposed to be five foot two the
doctor told me my whole life yeah
and you beat it i beat it man it up
thank you that's awesome nick was
premature baby man he's doing great
damn nice nice so we got a lot of
comeback kids up in here
that's what's up um no bro but this dude
thomas johnson i never seen him throw a
punch once in his life
because any time he would get an
altercation with someone the move he
would do because he was little also
is he would start looking around bro
like he would start looking around and
it would freak people out because he'd
be like
because he'd think that you know the
other person thought that he was going
to smoke him like because no teachers
were watching or anything oh so it was a
bit of a
kind of pomp and circumstance kind of
yeah yeah yeah when
when you're little man you got to have
like little tactics all you got to do
like i would look on the ground for
stuff if i felt someone was going to you
know
go off on me i'd start to like look at a
stick or look at a cone or something you
know so what you can do
strategize a little bit or something or
just have some like maybe oh he's not
looking at me right now like he must be
thinking something like just something
or like uh or yeah just confusing bro
it's the art of war
you know like anytime you can create
some chaos in the other person's mind
you do it
damn yeah do you use like is that
something that you still kind of go on
today like
because some guys do a lot of like um
peacock you know shawn's kind of a
peacock kind of guy
um sugar shawn and uh connor actually is
one of the more famous ones
um do you that doesn't really seem to be
your vibe as much
do you feel like there's stuff like that
when you get right into the octagon that
you're doing
or is there subtle things that maybe
that we wouldn't notice unless you told
us i think that i think that people
carry around energy
obviously and like pretty much the
entire time i'm in fight week or
i'm uh or definitely when we're facing
off or anything
in my head i'm thinking i'm gonna kill
you
you know you know next time next time we
see each other i'm gonna try to kill you
so i try to carry i try to carry that
energy with me all the time because oh
okay you know i think that
while it's subtle i think like you know
people pick up on that for sure
oh i can feel it right now dude even
though you're just kind of like you know
putting in the air just to kind of show
it it's kind of crazy because i really
can feel like
not that you're trying to kill me but
just that you're putting that thing out
there like this
like this force field almost you know
this thing like i'm gonna let this sit
in the air
because it's an ambiance that i built
inside of me and it has arms
that can reach out into the air that's
crazy right yep yep it does uh i think
one of the
you know most interesting things that
one of my buddies said to me one time is
he goes uh
he goes man like you're a really nice
like quiet guy you know soft spoken but
like
it wouldn't surprise me if you were out
there like being a serial killer or
something i was like
thank you bro thank you and that's
that's what i'm trying to put out there
you know
dang man um did anybody when you were
growing up was there anybody that had
that like a vibe that you didn't
ever know how they were feeling like
they
i'm just trying to wonder where some of
that comes from if that's just like a
just like a thing you that you choose as
a fighter or whether growing up was
there ever
like i never knew how my mom felt
growing up like she was always just
working real hard
but i never knew when she got home if
she was gonna be
like in a good mood i just never knew
really what was going on with her did
you have like was there anybody in your
life like that growing up where you just
kind of
and there doesn't have to be i'm just
kind of i i don't think so i don't even
really think that
you know you can definitely pick up on
energy when you're about to fight
someone you know like where they are in
their
in their headspace i think that wow your
body goes through some type of like
survival mechanism also where like it's
it's reading the other person a little
bit closer than i think that you know
like right now
and we're just having a conversation i
think when you're about to fight you're
able to read body language a little bit
easier and
i think that they're able to read theirs
a little bit easier so
um as you know i think that that's a big
part of the sport though is like
yeah that like body language reading you
know that energy type of reading and
uh but now growing up i i definitely
didn't have that skill so i don't really
really
yeah so it wasn't something so did you
think of yourself as like a tough kid
growing up
i knew that i was tough like i was a
very like physical kid
like i was really aggressive but like i
said man like i had to be humble because
i was so little
right i think that the people in the
smaller weight classes have to be humble
because
look man i'm a 135 and like i i noticed
that there's a different way
that 35ers act and like the littler
weight classes act versus like the
170 and up because like us even though
we can
be more skilled than a lot of the other
people uh
or the heavier weight classes like those
people you know like the law of nature
is the bigger animal usually beats the
smaller animals so like
i think just growing up smaller you have
to be a little bit more humble in those
ways
right yeah i could see that yeah it's
just kind of like
um yeah even the wrestlers in school
had a different energy than the f had to
have a different energy than the
football team
like the football team kind of got all
the a lot of the looks and the
the the accolades and like they got to
really be boastful and wear the
letterman jackets
but the wrestlers had to have almost
this more like
quiet uh
hungry yeah yeah literally a hungry vibe
yeah literally
yeah yeah and be more like a quiet
commander of themselves kind of you know
yeah did you play anything you're a big
dude man i didn't expect you to be that
really
bro i'm just pretty much regular-sized
yeah i'm dancing i'm built like
um
like a uh gingerbread man when you pull
up a gingerbread cookie now
i'm definitely built like a gingerbread
cookie uh
that hair looks way better in real
person too oh thanks bro yeah i mean
yeah i was gonna try to grow one out but
you messaged me too late bro you gotta
give me a couple months next time
have a rat tail next time dude i could
see you maybe with a rat that's how i'm
built see that
i got that body physique like a
gingerbread man without the uh
the the sugar art on it but uh yeah i'm
really just close-knit bro
not a ton of dexterity i'm built like a
conestoga wagon
right there exactly how i'm building
narrow body dude not
like you know um yeah like
i can go over some bumps dude but i'll
easily go off a cliff you know if i get
a little too close to the edge
what'd you play bro i play basketball oh
nice i played basketball growing up too
you did yeah yeah oh yeah that's right i
read that somewhere
yeah yeah um so i gotta ask this man
we'll
bring it we'll show this picture that we
show a lot of me playing some hoops
right here
um there we go right there that's me on
the squad right there bottom left
[Laughter]
and a lot of these man dude had children
had a lot of these men had just
like a college
[Laughter]
this is seventh grade baby right there
you were big back then too
dude i was a long guy bro i was
doing a good carried a lot of weight in
my ears back in
their ears and nose bro that's what my
yeah my ears only got bigger after the
cauliflower here
that's crazy so how long does it take to
start that cauliflower ear how do the
pumpkins take to really sprout
it's like a you know i it's like because
it's the skin and then like your
cartilage
the skin gets away from the cartilage by
getting like banged up or whatever
fills up with blood and then you know
depending on how well you take care of
it depends on like how much you have
so like some guys you see have like nice
cauliflower here this one bro was like
the size of a ping-pong ball in there
and uh
i would just drain it and drain it and
drain it because i didn't want to stop
training and i definitely didn't want to
wear a headgear so i would just keep
draining it and draining it and then one
day i
wasn't able to drain it anymore because
the king's supers i used to go to
to get the syringes because you do it
with the syringe oh yeah just
quit giving me syringes no they're like
no kid yeah
they're like they're like no kid like
you've been here every day for the last
two months
you don't get any more needles you know
like this kid's putting heroin into his
ears
or maybe they were doing it for the drug
addicts actually now that i think about
it maybe
hey man we're running out of needles man
some people need those yeah it could
have been man
maybe yeah maybe people the wire might
have been put back on hbo
um i remember using uh steroids and we'd
have to go to like a place and convince
him to give us the needles when i was in
high school
and that was always awkward the
lies we would make up for a dog as we
would always say
dude like one kid said it was for
this is the worst dude my friend was
such an idiot he said it was for his um
voodoo doll he's like well just
get some regular needles
you don't need like hypodermic syringes
unless you're voodoo dolls
really going through some tough
you know um dude you're really becoming
like a
a star in your sport have you
always felt uh what are some of the
things that happen with
ego and stuff like that that start to
happen that come with popularity because
that's a real thing and it's some
it's out of your control some of it's
out of your control like
that more eyes start to see you and more
people are curious about you like
there's nothing you as a person can do
about that you're just achieving your
goals
um what's it been like kind of like
noticing some of that
and um and responding to it yeah
i mean i'll answer and then i would
actually like to hear your answer to the
same thing to be honest because
i don't feel like you know i'm near the
caliber of something that you're at you
know but one day i would like to be too
but
uh i think man like i got you know
really fortunate in uh one the coach
that i i'm with right now
who uh his name is christian allen um
who taught me a lot about all of that
way way from the beginning
uh where i was kind of being you know
prepped and primed in order to kind of
like
not not deal with success but just to
deal with the everyday
egos of life and stuff so man i lost my
first
fight maybe like five years ago now um
and uh when i lost that fight i had to
do a lot of soul searching because i had
put a lot of my identity
in being a fighter and and being this
like you know prospect and
you know upping like i was supposed to
win every single fight i went into i was
supposed to win because i was supposed
to be the guy
and i had always come from a really good
gym like i came from grudge where like
some really really top-level guys came
from brendan used to train there all of
those guys
um so when i lost my first fight i had
to really do some searching you know
uh i spent about six months probably you
know thursday to sunday
every day in the mountains either
camping or hiking or both
and that's kind of where i learned to
like meditate learn to silent my mind
and just kind of you know like listen to
that little ego that's inside your head
because it'll chirp off you know like it
still chirps off no matter how much
i feel like i do still you know of
course uh
so man like i i know that it's in there
right like i know that you know uh
it's in there like it wants power it
wants to conquer it wants to it wants
things you know like every need is an
ego to feed
there's a you know a bob marley from a
bob marley song but uh
it's still in there man but i think it's
just more about like how how do you
respond to it best in a way where
it doesn't impact relationships with
yourself uh
and with other people because i mean at
the end of the day man like we're humans
we're social animals like
i think that that's more or less why
we're on the planet is to interact and
to love each other
and all of that jazz um
and i think that if you let your ego get
in the way of those types of things
that's where the ego really
is taking over your life you know so i
just try to keep it right underneath
that
but but right at the level where it's
like nah but when i go in the cage i'm
still trying to
you know win and and get all the things
i want because i want a lot of things in
my life
right yeah so still able to like just
kind of almost corral it like at least
have some control over it
sure that's interesting yeah i think
meditation is probably really really key
to that kind of stuff
you know do you do it i don't do it as
much as i as i
should and i can feel when i'm not doing
it yeah i can
feel like like the
uneasiness inside of me it's the
uncertainty yes
and i can feel it start to push from the
inside of me out towards onto my
like the inside of my skin yep yep so
it's funny when i know i have more
control over that
like um things roll off my shoulders
easier
i don't give in to like a lot of the
traps of my brain
and of society and i'm a little bit more
in control of myself and then i feel
like i can also do my best work than
just as a human
yeah not even as like a comedian or a
podcaster
but just as a human as a brother as a
son as a
friend as a co-worker all that kind of
stuff you know what uh
how do you make the clutter go away then
um i think
a lot of times i'll you use yoga right
now and then i just started getting into
doing um jiu jitsu
nice i'm white belt hell yeah so they
give it to you when you get there but i
am
uh i'm a certified white belt so
uh yeah so that's been cool man i never
realized how much
um anger i had in this this goes back to
what you were asking me about my answer
to that question was
man when i like about two years ago i
kind of got
into a space where i was just getting
more popular and
um and i think
something i had a lot of anger i got a
lot of anger because i i
i think i always thought inside of
myself when i got to a certain level
of achievement whatever we view
achievement as or success whatever
it doesn't have to be monetary success
but it could just be
a platform or finally having your voice
heard or
um finally achieving your physical
potential like just if
when i got to a certain level of success
that i was going to feel
a level of accomplishment that that
matched it or that
i don't know that the world was going to
be different yeah suddenly the problems
the uncertainties the
the low self-worth all that would
be completely gone
and i think when i started to arrive at
some of those places it wasn't
and i realized you're still just stuck
with just
re just life yeah that you know like it
still pisses you off when someone cuts
you off in traffic yeah everything's
still
never gonna go away yeah you're still
life doesn't come out and say there's
nothing that there's not like a magical
waterfall that opens up and a man or
woman walks out and says congratulations
you did it yeah there's never that thank
you for your effort
um i think there's something inside of
me i think
it got so angry because there wasn't
like a
you know you don't get the golden orb or
whatever that quidditch ball you don't
get
you know there's no big thank you for
your effort yeah
and uh and that made you angry it made
me angry i didn't know what was going on
it was just inside of me and so i think
i got so angry
and i was having trouble finding a place
to put it and then
since i started going to the jujitsu gym
man i get
it literally has to come out of me
because i'm caged up by some 50
or 60 year old man yeah and i can't
do anything you know
or they put me against some you
know adderall now
six five guy the white belts are the
most dangerous guys bro
i'm fighting a guy that drives a bread
truck dude all night he hasn't even
slept and he's in there
the guy's jacked just taking
caffeine pills before bro
that's a real thing man we got a couple
guys like that too at the gym
crazy bro so but just my
me wanting to wanting something and not
having any control over it
that's those moments where i'm just
caged up i can't move somebody i can't
and i'm trying with part muscles in my
nut muscles i didn't even know were in
my body i'm trying with
and having no and and there's no return
from the world
yeah and it's like it kind of answered
that
that question that i had where i wanted
some return and then it's like jiu jitsu
shows you that there's just
there's no return but it's kind of okay
yeah and you go back to a place where
you each shake each other's hand and
it's all good and
and you try and learn a different way
next time
um yeah who's good for that man jiu
jitsu is good because i think that you
know like uh
so i don't know how closely you followed
all of my fighting and stuff but in the
in the last two fights i've really
like uh come to find you know i don't
want to call it like anger but that
place where like i know
that i have to go out and be a different
person than like when i'm walking
day to day oh your confidence has
changed even from the outs of the al jos
fight your confidence seems different
when you are
in there when you're entering as a
viewer it seems
different um yeah what do you attribute
that to
kind of uh i upped the meditations i
upped the visualizations
uh i started feeding my brain different
things uh
because like i said man like um
i like to think that you know a lot of
life is about relationships and loving
each other and this and that you know
and uh
you know i've read i've done my fair
share of reading on like eastern
philosophy
and you know eliminating the ego
eliminating desires and
you know all of that jazz and i realize
that that's really great to like be able
to like you know
conquer conquer like some peace inside
you you know and be able to like do that
i think after you do that though if
you're gonna be in the world that i'm in
you need to you need to also like
conquer war you know and you need to
learn a lot about that and you need to
and you need to know how to get there
you know so
um the point that i was bringing up man
is that like
that's inside of everyone you know like
the same type of anger and like you know
like let me get this out type of feeling
i think is inside of everyone i don't
think everyone gets to experience it and
i don't think that everyone gets to
see it as a positive thing and because i
always saw it as not a positive thing
and when someone would walk out or after
a fight act like a you know like an
arrogant
idiot you know like i would judge that
person you know
and then i got to thinking after i lost
i was like man like
there is a level of peacocking happening
there is a level of
intimidation like there is a level of
manipulation like
there's a reason that like warriors in
the past
used to torture each other it's not
because they liked it it's because
if i torture this person and and i
peacock because that was kind of their
version of peacocking
that's going to scare the other side
right the other guys sitting around the
ring who are fighting me next or who i
might run around the next corner
they're going to see me differently yep
they're going to see me differently and
uh
it's true man it's true man and i think
uh there's a lot that's like a separate
art in itself
is just like the being able to get
yourself to a state where it's like
nothing else matters
except for beating this person nothing
else matters
uh and that's why i've been going in in
the last couple
times you know and i attribute it to a
lot of meditations but i'm doing
different kind of meditations i know
everyone kind of throws that word around
and
i'm not a guru or anything so i don't
know the terminology or whatever but
in my experience there's a lot of
different kinds so now i'll do somewhere
it's like
instead of making myself really peaceful
now it's time to go on that other end of
the spectrum and be able to you know if
i can quiet my mind great but now let's
kind of like wake it up you know or not
wake up the mind but wake up the body to
a point where it's like
when it's go time like i can actually go
you know and uh
so a lot of it is that man and just
figuring that out yeah it's an
interesting philosophy really
um to create that angst in you
because there's one thing about getting
ready for something getting hyped
there's a there's one thing about
getting hyped for something
yeah like you could play basketball in
high school and stuff and get hyped for
it that's a different
let's go you know you're excited you got
you know you've done some warm-ups
there's a different thing about how do i
make myself
nes like that a victory is a necessity
you know how do i get the part of me
that when someone does something to me
and i can't do something back to them
that vitrol that arises
how do you create that in a moment
because the power of
that is so much more tangible
and real and vicious than the power of
okay let's just get hype
let me high five my buddies you
know it's just that's a different
world so to have a meditation for war
that's kind of fascinating man i had i
never even thought about that it's all
survival man
you know it's all survival and survival
that's a great word i i think that all
of our lives man because
um i used to work at a trauma facility
too for like uh
for kids that had like histories of
trauma and stuff and so
and i went to school for psychology uh
at cu boulder so
you know i'm no expert by any means you
know i was just on call i would just
fill in or whatever
like for for the the people that were
actually doing a lot of the work
at this place called mount saint
vincent's but wow it's a pretty powerful
place
it's a super powerful place man i think
that i would attribute a lot of like
what i've learned in life to that
facility
wow um i used to be there a lot more man
like like i said it was an on-call
position so it was like
i pretty much would make my own hours so
back before i was in the ufc and even
while i was in the ufc actually i just
resigned maybe a couple months ago
just because i still liked having it be
a part of my life
yeah um but yeah i was working there for
a while
uh and you you know like you learn a lot
about just like how the brain works
obviously but you learn that like man
we're all just
doing things in order for us to be able
to survive better
you know like the kids that i was
working with they developed a certain
amount of behaviors because
in because in their environments they
needed them you know and you're
preaching to the choir this is like
we talk about this all the time on this
podcast i still suffer from
survival skills that i needed from
trauma as a kid that i still use today
that
affect me negatively now yeah and that
becomes the problem is when you have a
certain survival set
in this environment but now you're
living in this environment and it's like
man i don't need those anymore
but for me man like i need a different
level of survival techniques in order
for me to go out into the cage
and to be able to perform at the highest
level that i can and like
i've i've learned what those survival
techniques are you know and
and i'm still figuring it out man like
even in the last fight that i had
against frankie like
i felt way more like uh powerful
you know when i was like i felt way more
powerful than even i did when i was
going against marlin
uh which was another really good fight
of mine right so you have marlon moraeus
yeah people say his last name different
people should meet before
and decide how they're gonna say his
last name you know what i'm saying let's
do that next time
but no man great both i mean both of
them were great fights but
no it's interesting to see so so
starting to recognize that there's other
skills you can
still master outside of and not even
master but start
start to learn and navigate outside of
just the ones
that would seem like the most uh the
most popular
for fighters yeah that that's everything
to me man like
uh everyone's good bro like everyone
that i'm gonna fight for the rest of my
career is going to be good it's going to
be good bro
i know bro i had that moment i had that
moment i forget when it was dude i think
it was like
dude it must have been uh that sucks it
was like
two years ago i was like i'm not wrecker
i'm not wrecking anyone anymore bro
i remember i had the moment i was
sitting there and i was thinking i was
like man i need to just get used to this
bro i was like
i like had an internal battle bro i was
like man
every single dude for the next probably
10 years is gonna like
be at this level you know that's crazy
yeah it sucked to come to that
conclusion but
you know i've settled into it um
it was let's get that question up of
nick about the hours minutes and months
before
and you're chris allen's here that's
your coach yep yep that's awesome man
yeah that's cool for him to come out
yeah yeah me and him are best friends
too oh just me
oh yeah dude i would like to see you
guys do a tag team versus freaking uh
sugar shawn and tim welch one day though
for charity that'd be fun yeah what kind
of match what like
i don't know maybe whatever like it
could just be video games what are those
things what are those things you take to
the pool
it could be noodles yeah noodles there
we go you know recently i realized i was
paying 300
for car insurance and then i did some
adjustment
now i'm not even joking i'm paying 53
now is something wrong if i get an
accident am i actually covered i have no
idea
i need to check more but the bottom line
is that
it has been reported that americans
overall
are spending 21 billion
dollars on our auto insurance
overpaid overpaying that much overpaying
21 billion
that's insane thankfully the zebra
is the nation's leading car insurance
comparison site
you can do a comparison and know what's
going on before you couldn't do it
you had to ask somebody and you'd ask
somebody else and drive back and forth
across
town you know somebody's doing hate
crimes you gotta hope for the best
but that's all changed the zebra.com
the only place you can compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less
plus they will never sell your
information to the spammers
techcrunch calls the zebra kayak for
auto
insurance you can save up to 670 dollars
a year
how much can you save can you save
on car and home insurance go today
start saving the zebra.com
theo that's the zebra.com slash
t-h-e-o spelled t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash theo why not
you know what this time of year i
honestly i don't know sometimes
what's going on with my body and with
the weather and some
sometimes it's snowing or it's raining
and your body's full of hair
and your dick ain't right but everything
can be changed now
thanks to manscaped they are here to
provide
the best tools for your grooming
experience
offering precision engineered tools for
your family jewels
that's right we've all tried to shave
ourselves and not cut our bag
or uh or you know jimmy out of labia or
whatever
but now the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer is the
best hygiene tool for the modern man do
what you need get your body tight
manscapes performance package is the
best buy of 2021.
you can get 20 off and you can support
this podcast we need support
we need to stay in business you can get
free shipping by going to manscape.com
t-h-e-o that's 20 off with free shipping
by going to manscaped.com theo
thanks manscaped for making our winter
wieners
look good here's a guy right here who's
sending a question
all right here we go theo vaughn i'm
taking a for you and this question
is coming from the
corey sanhagen what's going on man much
love
um what's the mindset quick question
what's the mindset
going into a fight going into a ufc
world class fight against world-class
fighters um
what's the steps that you take weeks
before the fight
months before the fight and hours or
minutes right before you walk out
to prepare your mind whether that's
meditation or i don't even
reading type of like warrior books or i
don't really know learning about
conquistadors i think that's what
mike tyson used to do so i'm very
curious and said what your mental state
is and how you try to
keep a uh strong positive but motivated
very focused mental state
going into a fight so uh gang gang thank
you so much corey what's going on
gang bro thanks for the question i and
you answered some of it with the
meditation and some of you know the
the pro trying to perfect a different
mod like
mindset outside of the fighting exact
fist fist body my the body set
and more of a mindset but yeah going
into like like a
once you learn what the fight is what's
kind of the process from like okay
this is who i'm fighting now it's a week
before and now it's the day of yeah yeah
uh so i usually do 10-week camps
okay uh and this is actually something
that uh my training partner
carrington banks helped me a lot with
he's also in my corner too he's my
wrestling
you know helper i don't call him a coach
because you know he's still fighting
himself but it's like a peaking process
man like as you get closer to the fight
it's it's a peaking process so
10 weeks out i'm still doing you know
meditations every day i'm still doing
like breathing exercises
uh either before because before sparring
i'll do a lot of breathing exercises to
to get to that level of like you know
body
awareness and stuff will you load up on
uh on will you do that like
will you load up until you can hold your
breath for a long time no no uh
i it's similar to wim hof type of
breathing where it's like
really big uh or a really big long
inhale and then quick exhale yeah yeah
it's pretty similar to that
okay uh have you ever tried that yeah i
have man i held my breath one time like
three and a half minutes yeah it makes
me like all tingling yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm a fish it's pretty
much like that though
because it wakes your body up man it
gets like oxygen all around or whatever
so
it's that uh like i said man it's
feeding your brain the right stuff
that's funny that he brought up mike
tyson because i'll watch a lot of mike
tyson's interviews too and uh
just because i like seeing how really
high-level competitors think
uh and he'll talk about like napoleon uh
you know like um all of those like
generals and and back in the day and
that's what i was talking about too is
the feed in the mind
like feeding the mind war stuff is you
know part of my survival now
so i do a lot of that um
okay so that was kind of like in it so
that's early in advance so then once you
get like
you're going through camp you're getting
close to a few weeks out is there does
anything change or does
camp just stay the same up until like
the day of the fight i would say about
three weeks out
and i don't know that i really do it on
purpose i think that when you stay like
connected
with like you know your your your you
inside of you you know uh i think that
things just happen naturally the way
that you
you want it to so about three weeks out
man i don't
for whatever reason every single
stressor in my life doesn't matter
anymore
wow but up until then like i'll i'll
still you know because i'm hungry i'm
training hard
so i'll be like pissed off about like
little right like i'll come home
uh i have a a roommate that lives
downstairs
and my girlfriend that lives with me and
i'll get home sometimes man and they'll
be in the kitchen like
you know going flirting flirting with
each other bro
i'll walk in and get so mad because the
energy is just like too high you know
like that's that's where i'm at about
like i felt like three weeks before i'm
just like
i'm going on a walk walking this is like
you just got
home like turn this energy down you know
it's
too happy and are you happy in
here
okay i'll knock some over
yeah you know we put apocalypto
on or something
i do start watching a little bit more
violent stuff as it gets closer too but
yeah man about three weeks away for
whatever reason
things stop mattering to me and it's all
just like
let's let's get this done you know let's
get this done so but i think that that
comes just from you know staying checked
in not letting myself get cluttered
you know the the more i feel cluttered
the
the less i just feel connected to myself
and so uh
yeah man it's that stuff okay yeah yeah
you know i can really
it's all it's in a weird way sometimes
some of that reminds me what you're
saying like with comedy when i'm on
stage if
i if i'm in a space where i'm not tied
to a bunch of other that day before
i get on the stage or something and i'm
really just
feeling like part of the universe a
little bit and like
like locked in and wanting to have a
good show and make sure these people
have fun
it's not exactly the same but it's just
on the same like wavelength of like um
i'm not attached to too many other
things man then i'm almost
i'm almost just my skills are already
they are there
you know they definitely can always be
better but i'm just working off this
energy that's in the world and it's just
a
yeah it's like i'm just juggling this
dope that god put out
yeah yeah you know like you're just
where you're supposed to be yeah dude i
saw you in denver not too long ago man i
have to say just because i'm a fan boy
too bro
uh it was probably like last year bro
yeah um because i hadn't seen your
stand-up until
probably your comedy centrals or did you
have anything on netflix too
yeah i did a netflix express about five
years ago yeah yeah i think that was the
last one that i watched and then i
watched you in denver and it was like
way different than
the stand-up that you were doing before
oh sweet dude it was sick
was it good yeah bro it was so creative
oh thanks it was like
i don't know i don't know yeah because
because i'm really interested in comedy
i'm like a big fan of comedy
too oh i like like all the different
styles that all you guys have and stuff
and like
yeah man i was just like well that was
weird and it was like so good you know
thanks bro it is super good man yeah was
that at uh
the something north or whatever that
place was no uh yeah
uh the one that's outside of town a
little uh yeah out of denver yep yep
yeah yeah yeah that's a fun that room is
really funny you're almost like in the
round kinda
yeah that's what everyone says dude
thanks for coming out bro that's awesome
yeah man yeah man
that's cool man uh yeah dude um
yeah that's awesome man i appreciate you
i appreciate you coming on you know i
got to meet at a show one time too
was uh anthony lionheart smith came out
to a show
which was pretty cool dude he's a cool
dude yeah this is like three or four
years ago yeah
such the nicest dude and then poirier
came and i had a show in
new orleans about three years ago and he
came and literally the whole time he was
this is back when he was still like
he's definitely like still can be as
angry as he wants to be
but he was almost like posted up at the
edge of the at the edge
he's the only person not in a seat bro
just ready to go to
war back again
thomas used to do dude yeah yeah it was
it was pretty it was pretty it
was interesting man
he's a cool dude too huh he's a nice guy
is his hot sauce good
it is good bro i'll see i'll get you
some i'll get you some of his scent how
many are there like 10 different flavors
there's a lot no he just has one his own
one flavor
but it is good he's cool man i think uh
he was talking about some anger after
his last fight remember after seeing him
in the cage against conor he was like
he was happy obviously because he'd won
but he was like upset
he's like i don't love this no more
stuff i think a lot of it was yeah
i think a lot of it was like um
i think first i don't know um this is
all speculation i think some of it was
like
that belt in their weight division
it's kind of become this ornament and
not a real
reflection of who is at the top
dude i've almost always felt like
chasing a belt
is kind of it's you know it's a goal
but it's like man you can only control
so much in that world man
like what if you know what if dustin
doesn't fight for the belt next you know
right yeah or what if i don't
you know like that don't that doesn't
feel like as in control as
maybe it used to be or maybe it was an
illusion and now that i'm here it's like
oh no there's like a lot of other
factors that go into
winning a belt other than just me
beating people
right so it's kind of weird man and it's
just a weird place in the sport too
where it's like
you know uh it's kind of the fame game a
little bit
you know like you got to be a little bit
up in like your social media account and
all of that jazz in order to kind of
get what you want yeah or at least to be
able to call a little bit of the shots
right which is fine that's the world
that we live in now so yeah it's a
business
i think in you guys business too and you
guys is
i think the longer you're in it it's the
longer you're in anything
it re it's more of a business like i
used to go to the comedy clubs and i was
just excited if people were there
and then you do it doing it for 15 years
you're like well did we sell tickets you
know it's like
some of that gets in your head somewhere
you know like is
is the audience happy like you just
you're just you start to have more
concerns
i think some of that's just life um but
yeah i mean you guys are in a business
that was bit like
everything's a business it's a society's
just kind of like this
structure yeah of of things that were
put together by people you know um
when you we got a question right here
from a young fellow
what's up theo what's up cory dallas
from staten island new york here
huge fan of both of you guys theo me my
wife got to see you about a year ago
out in red bank new jersey the show was
crazy hoping we can see you again real
soon oh thanks brother cory my question
for you is
how well do you really know brendan shop
because he's always talking about he's
texting him he's talking to after your
fights
besides food truck diary i know you guys
are from aurora colorado
let them know people are doubting i'm
not a doubter i know you guys know each
other
let the world know gang gang saying moon
there you go are people down now what is
there to doubt
people brendan gets doubted a lot i
think but
so i think people want to know yeah he
has that look bro
yeah i think brendan says that yeah he
has and he has nine different
shows i think people just start to doubt
him you know he's a chef he runs a food
he says something different on each one
just to accommodate to each different
audience so i think people are like what
is the truth here brendan
you guys never fought each other right
no no no hell no
no when i was uh when i was 17 or 18
years old
we were all training at this gym called
grudge and uh it's like where all the
really good guys train like uh shaw was
there
ludwig was there marquardt was there uh
gsp would stop in rashad evans like all
of those really really big names
um and so i used to train there when i
was like you know like a
140 pounds like soaking wet you know uh
and probably you know maybe shouldn't
have been in that room at that time but
uh yeah i mean we're all in that room
together and i think that you know while
me and
brendan were never like you know i was
17 years old he was fighting in the ufc
it's not like we were hanging out
right that would be a little weird
actually but yeah because he would be an
adult
yeah that'd be illegal also probably
uh but i mean not man we share that like
those same aurora roots you know like
it's just
like i said man it's like a community
aurora feels like a community yeah yeah
yeah was he the kind of guy if he went
and asked him for a suggestion he would
like advice or something he would share
it he was definitely
i think so yeah uh everyone was pretty
cool at grudge
uh yeah brennan was definitely like one
of the superstars there
for sure during that time it's so funny
because i don't know
like to me i don't know about that as as
that at all like i don't i don't ever
even see that look in his eyes anymore
like
you know what it takes to be if i like
not that he doesn't have it i'm not
saying that
but he doesn't never turn that on in any
environment that he and i are ever in no
longer part of his survival
yeah it's probably true yeah it's
probably no longer part of his survival
man
um dude this was heartbreaking man i
even i remember
i put a comment on your ig after your
last fight and it was barely even like
i was like way to go good job it was so
like i
but also it was like frankie edgar's
just like beloved by humanity and i know
by you as well
how hard is that man like is
because no other like i guess there's
other sports where that kind of stuff
happens but
how hard is it to go out there and fight
like
a guy well here is he asking it right
here we'll we'll let this guy ask us so
because he sent it in
hey corey being a fighter you know
you're going to every fight trying to
win of course
but as a human as a human being how did
it feel
knocking a legend like frankie edgard
out
uh that should shook me for sure i know
a lot of people were
still sure gang gang
gang bro uh yeah man there's like i said
man there's two different people for me
man like there's you know i gotta be a
type of way when i go in the cage and i
can be a different type of way when i'm
out but
uh you know what the the craziest part
of
am i trying to put you on the spot no no
it's okay no no i don't i don't mind at
all bro i'm not curious about like you
her i i'm just genuinely curious about
the sides of it yeah yeah so once i'm
done you know without adrenaline dump
that happens
i mean i almost felt like crying when i
was in there not
well one because yeah man like frankie's
a legend
uh i know he's a good dude um
you know and i know that he's trying to
provide for his family and stuff and so
that sucks
what trips me out the most about
something like that
is that not because i'm worried about
frankie because i know that we're all
really
tough dudes you know like we can handle
it um
but just like knowing that he has loved
ones that are watching
oh yeah and that i was a part of that
and that i probably created you know
like
some definite sadness in in that that's
what like
you know makes you want to cry yeah
because we're all tough dudes man but
like
i remember having that thought when they
were raising my hand where it's like man
like his
his kids saw it you know like these kids
are probably worried about him his wife
is probably worried about him and like
that that part really sucks
yeah that part really really sucks you
know there's no getting around how much
that sucks
yeah but you know what sucks worse huh
is that happening to me right damn
that's what sucks worse
and that's some of the truth of it
that's the truth and that's i mean
that's kind of like
you know pory always talks about that's
like the beautiful thing about it he's
like there's this
it's just this it's this inescapable
like
it's almost like how the world was
started like this big bang theory like
you know things broke apart for
something to be
made like it's just i don't know it's
just
it's sad man it's sad when you lose i
know what it feels like man like i was
choked out by sterling like i know
i know what it feels like man to open
your eyes see the person
running around the cage excited like you
know pump that he won
and to have the doctor lift you up and
sit you on the stool
like i know how that feels man like it
sucks and who was y'alls ref no nonsense
keith peterson
uh for the last one yeah i think i think
so yeah
why you like him the most i would fight
him
you're a lot bigger than him i'll
lose weight i'll cuddle
what would you do bro what would be the
strategy if you had a fight
by winning against no nonsense in nnkp
[Laughter]
first i would probably i would try i'll
probably try to wear him down dude
yeah i'll probably try to wear him down
how would you do that i'd get him up
in the cage first i'd run him i'd run
him down i got tired oh okay yeah okay
i'd run him until i got tired and then i
would get him up against the cage bro
and i'd probably would you foot stomp
her knee or
i'd do a little bit of that kamaru
yeah stomp on his feet hold him
against the cage and stomp on his feet
until he can barely move his feet and
then i'd hard scarf him dude i'd
sneak up behind him
i'd get him distracted and i'd sneak up
behind him have somebody wave a
cigarette or something in the distance
sneak up behind him and put him in the
hard scarf bro
that's a hard scarf is that oh
yeah until you finish him out yeah yeah
um but anyway and look i'm just joking
keith peterson
unless we're like raising money for
charity i'm a big i'm a keith peterson
fan yeah me too
so uh he's a good ref man i like the
refs that don't say anything
the refs that talk man i can't stand the
refs that talk really
yeah oh i can't stand it man just
because it's like man no one came to
watch you bro it's not something no one
you know that's nonsense man yeah
i like to think about zero nonsense bro
um do bigger fights get bigger
is there like a ref order that feels
like yeah i think that there is there
definitely is
um because herb dean gets a lot of the
big ones right yeah he gets a lot of big
ones uh
no nonsense gets a lot of the big ones
uh i like most of the refs but there's a
couple refs where i'll be watching on
the tv and i'm just like just shut up
like he's not he's not doing what you're
saying because i've been on the other
end of that where
a ref has been like quit grabbing his
shorts and it's like in my head i got to
be like i'm not grabbing his shorts
what's he talking about and then that
just distracts you and when it's like a
game of inches it's like dude shut up
right yeah yeah shut up dude nobody yeah
no one came to watch yeah you weren't
there training with us you weren't you
don't know anything about it yeah i
could see that that's interesting
yeah um yeah so that's yeah that's
interesting man it's an it's kind of a
it's it's a i think it's definitely a
different and comforting thought though
to know that there's some level of that
within the fighters that
there's all like yes that could also be
me
and we both came into this knowing that
that kind of thing can happen
and that there's some sense of like res
like um
care concern for the person's family you
know or for the people that are caring
about them watching him
you know i i think you have to be a
little bit on the other side or at least
have had to experience it to kind of
like fully understand that yeah because
like if you look at ancient samurais
like ancient samurais
you know they're known for like you know
obviously being like badass fighters but
they're also known for like the way that
they used to live
and the way that they used to live is
like very honorable very respectful to
to everyone else and like it got me
thinking it's like man like
how can these really brutal soldiers who
slash people up with swords also live in
a way where it's like
okay i have a i have honor and i have
respect
for fellow human beings and and i'll and
i'll do this this and this to show that
or or
or i'll even like go as far as to stab
myself to keep honor of
whatever you know like i think it takes
a level of like
having to go through all of those brutal
feelings and understand that like you
know this is
not always fun and games like poirier
said
uh in order to kind of like fully
respect
the other side of it which is like life
and you know and like when you actually
win
like how to be a winner because you know
what it's like to be the loser and right
i think that that's important you know
but that's interesting that porya said
that uh it's not fun to him anymore
he actually says a lot of interesting
stuff dude that's a funny thing and
that's one thing i always liked about
dustin since i met him was that
there's so much more to him than a
fighter you know and i think for a lot
of guys
it's interesting to see them
get to
come into whatever else they are as
humans
and i think the world has really gotten
to witness that of dustin over the past
few years you know like
just through his charity and through um
you know through his journey to get paid
through the organization like just
um you know like i know when he and tony
let that fight go it was because of
money i believe i think he said that
i i don't want to be talking out of
school but um
so yeah to try and stand on some sense
of honor and still
you know grow up and
yeah i just think it's interesting i
think it's interesting why people fight
you know i was always like afraid to
fight as a kid so i'm like
like and then but then we're all
fighting for something in some way you
know we're all trying to like find some
way to express ourselves
so i guess sometimes i wonder if
fighting is just
a way that you guys express yourself
i i always does it feel like that i
always wonder this i always wonder like
okay am i working harder than other
people in other professions and
or or is me winning feel better
because of you know it's fighting or
does it does it feel worse to lose
because it's fighting or whatever and i
think that anything that you try to do
at like your best if you don't reach
that like it's still going to suck for
everyone
you know so i i think that it's like
yeah it's like this expression of
yourself or whatever but i think that
yeah man it's just like
i don't know why people want to play the
piano all day but there's some people
out there that want to play the piano
all day and then there's
like some people that want to like do
math equations all day yeah and like to
me that seems like hell
but like i don't you know i don't i
don't know what that is in different
people or what but like
that crosses my mind all the time it's
like man you couldn't have chosen
something different
podcasting can i done drywall yeah
something have you ever drywalled bro
that shit's worse than fighting bro it's
a gateway drug too dude there's no way
you start drywall and don't end up doing
drugs
true um here's a question right here
wait is this my uh is this
what's this guy's name uh does he say it
yo theo nick corey what's going on guys
it's your boy chico from st louis
missouri here
got a couple quick questions for the
sandman cory first off congrats on the
huge knockout of frankie the answer
edgar
had to have felt crazy knocking
out a legend like that um but congrats
again
i'd love to know what you think of the
matchup between al jermain sterling and
peter yan
i know you lost to al jermaine you know
a couple months ago and that was your
first loss since 2017. so
what do you think of that match up and
also are you itching to get a rematch at
al jermaine so
who do you think's going to win that
fight and who do you want to win that
fight
uh much love to you guys gang gang take
care yeah how do you feel like that
al jeremy's such a nice guy too man how
do you feel about uh their fight coming
up
are you excited to watch it yeah i'm
super pumped to watch it uh i
i think it's gonna go like the entire
five rounds so like from a strategic
standpoint
i like to like you know i think that
i'll get like a lot of knowledge yeah
uh but i don't know man i flip a coin
every single time like every time i get
asked i just change my answer depending
on the day so
i think stylistically and like
technically better
i think jan's probably the maybe the
better uh technical fighter but being a
being a technical fighter doesn't mean
that you're the better fighter i
you know i've been in the cage with
algerman and he has a level of intensity
like we were talking about before with
the energy
uh that's a lot different than everyone
else that i fought
um so you know i think that he really
has that going for him
and i think you know algeman's been
really open about his strategy
about this like he keeps talking about
how he's gonna wrestle the guy for five
rounds
i don't know how smart it is to reveal
your strategy like that but
uh he must be really confident in it so
you know and i do think that his
grappling and just him in general is
really underrated like i think he's
he's definitely way up there as far as
fighters go in the ufc and
uh i don't know man if if you had to ask
me for whatever reason i i kind of
i just like i like al jamaine a little
bit so like i always you know
i root for people not fun to cheer for
yeah yeah yeah there's something
there's something about him that's very
fun to cheer for um
yeah that's gonna be interesting man
y'all's division is getting so
interesting they're good too man
everyone's really
like we're talking about man everyone's
good bro yeah everyone's good it's crazy
does it start to get scary to think that
you might have to fight for like the
next 10 years does that start to ever
get spooky
it was it was spooky it was pretty
spooky until i like
until i accepted it man like i told you
it was just like this moment where i was
like
i think it was after uh i thought this
guy do you know who john lineker is
he don't fight in the ufc anymore bro
but he's like five foot two
built like a brick and like his head is
you know like this big
uh any like cracks bro like he cracks it
was it was my third fight in the ufc i
was
so scared to fight that dude and then
after i beat john lineker
i was like damn man like every single
fight yeah yeah that's john
oh yeah dude i've definitely seen him at
panama city spring break before
dude yeah bro not happy he's the one
he's running sprints in the sand bro
yeah dude he's doing
sprints at the bar there's always that
guy man i'm just doing push-ups in the
bathroom bro i'm just joking dude
uh wow yeah yeah so after i
fought him because he was right he was
in the top 10 for my third ufc fight and
uh after i fought john that's when it
kind of hit me where i was like yep
this is going to be hard for the next 10
years of my life you know it's kind of
like playing punch out after you beat or
like a
boxing after you beat a hard guy you
have to pause it and then like you kind
of go get some waters when you come back
you're like
man they're all going to be really
hard from that one yeah and dude you
know what else too is like uh
everyone will be like ah like cool you
get to like take a little break after
you win blah blah blah it's like no i
don't
you know like i kind of do just from
like the the warrior
part of me like i can be a lot less
competitive now but
as far as like me getting better man
like this only gets harder bro like
it only gets harder the better people i
beat the harder i got to work it's like
i thought it'd be the opposite i thought
i'd get into the ufc
i'd start you know i'd start winning and
like i'd get into a groove and
would be
easier and more routine but like man
like it's just harder every every time i
win i'm just like all right well that
was the last easiest fight of your life
yeah that's crazy that sucks but now
that i just said it that sucks but
that's
but hearing that to me it makes perfect
sense because that's the thing inside of
you that makes you what you are anyway
it's that thing it's like the next uh
there's always something else yeah you
know i'm always gonna have to learn
there's always
more to learn or more to do it's always
yeah it's the challenge bro it's all
like uh that this is why it interested
me when poirier said
uh this isn't even fun for me anymore
like i i almost feel the same way
depending on how you define fun right if
fun means like oh i'm enjoying myself
it's not fun i'm not enjoying any part
of that process like
i see people even the week of the fight
it's like oh like okay this is my taper
week like
i can i can kick back and like i can
enjoy my fight week and i'll go like jet
ski or
you know visit this or visit that or
whatever and it's like
dude during fight week i lay in bed
and i just think about the the fight and
what i'm supposed to do
and that's all i do like i watch maybe
one or two hours of tv i maybe if i'm
getting a little overwhelmed in my head
we'll go like hang out with my coaches
and stuff but other than that man
i'm laying in bed resting my mind and
like getting myself ready to like do
this
it's like not enjoyable bro yeah even
camp
camp isn't even that enjoyable i would
say the most enjoyable part for me
in this whole thing is just uh coming up
with my own
and me and christian working together
and me and carrington working together
and me and
uh some of the jiu jitsu guys that i
work with like
inventing or like at least like trying
to get really good
at like the things that we're doing like
that's enjoyable for me
but like and like the winning part is
enjoyable but man like
everything else is just challenge it's
not like fun
right yeah i think there's something
that happens within success
man where some things kind of become
like that and that starts to become the
next
battle in some ways is uh any more water
no i'm good
that starts to become the next battle in
some ways is like how do
i make where i'm at now
as enjoyable as an experience as
possible
um did you go through that yeah man i
think it is
still enjoyable it's there's moments
that are enjoyable but it was i had a
lot more like
i remember dude when we were so when we
were getting dustin fourier on dude we
were so excited
dude we were so excited yeah salon
quality hairstyle was his nickname
and he was we were so
fired up dude and um
and i still get wakes it's not that
things aren't exciting
it's like i think some of it is you just
get
used to some stuff and there's nothing
you can do
that's just experience there's nothing
you can do to kind of go back to that
level of excitement you had like when
you were probably first
training and doing well against a guy at
grudge yeah
i mean my scariest fight was my first
fight yeah
my scariest like fight was my first
fight really yeah probably you know
because you know
you know it's like your first one was
was yours was it white belt
uh or what was it is it not even like
that dude
the white belt is just jiu jitsu yeah
yeah so i don't yeah so i don't consider
jiu jitsu matches
fights
[Laughter]
in my life but no respect bro yeah for
real bro
i'm just around bro but no no
totally i feel you but so
dude i i thought uh in this place um
bro i'm pretty sure it was like a house
dude like
like a gutted house bro i'm almost
positive it was like a gutted house it
was in the neighborhood bro
oh dude that's bad when you pull up to
the fight
and the driveway's full
so dude uh it was this uh more
sanctioned
no okay it was a it was a muay thai
tournament i was i think i was 18 years
old
dude i'm not kidding you bro the ring
was probably
much more actually the ring was probably
about this size bro
it was probably like an eight by eight
dude in like this gutted house
and like uh it was matted
eight by eight ring everyone was warming
up you like you sat on the floor
if you wanted to watch the fights you
just crowded around you watched the
fights
and uh yeah that was my first fight uh
or first tournament
and so that was one of the scariest
moments yeah that was one of the
scariest moments because it's just like
you know i i've never
really been in a fight against you know
like like an actual real fight i had
never been in before so
how real is this stuff they talk about
ring rust is that a real thing
i don't know i don't think i've ever
been out long enough to like
have experienced that but i do think
though that like when i fight
you know four months apart three months
apart i can kind of i feel a little bit
different like i feel
a lot more comfortable than i do if i'm
like on an eight eight month
break so with the with the upcoming
match you have to wait to see what
happens with one of these guys if that's
the guy you
choose to fight or that's the guy that
they want to match you with i hope so
um but there's not somebody else from
would they try and offer you somebody
from uh
that's that is in the rankings that's
beneath you currently
i think that uh me and dillashaw if they
don't do
dillashaw yeah i forgot about
him
they're bringing him back they got a
cheat code or something
uh yeah so that would be crazy huh
yeah i mean i i think if it's not the
winner of their fight then it's
i mean it's got to be dilla shaw because
i mean garbrandt's going down
uh i i i don't know what all those doing
font's really good but he's kind of in
the same position i was in maybe like
three fights ago where
uh you know i think that he font's
really good but i think he needs to
string like
you know some top five wins together
before i think they start considering
him for a title shot too
um is there somebody from the past that
you wish
was like somebody you would like to have
fought or fought not even out of anger
just
out of like pierce like it would be
awesome like somebody from the past that
you grew up watching or anything like
that
oh yeah yeah uh well cruz cruz was
definitely in that conversation for a
long time
uh he might fight he looks like you
climb over the cage and fight any day
most of the time
who cruise dominant cruz yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean he's always pretty
did he retire what happened i think he
might actually have something scheduled
casey kenny yeah he's fighting casey
kenny when is that one in march uh i
think it's sometime in march i like him
man i like watching yeah when he
when he's because you always you kind of
never know what he's going to say
sometimes he'll get a little bit angsty
with the other
yeah he's you know like he has something
about him that's
you know intimidating yeah you know i
like that it's cool
yeah yeah yeah he's on 259. nice wow
that's the 13th uh six oh oh he's on
that one yeah he's on that card yeah
that card is
that card is insane yeah my teammate
dober's fighting on that card too
um yeah who's on that card man that's
bananas
um three title fights
santos rockets oh yeah
this this fight is insane or a car
doesn't what do you think about that uh
block of its fight and arasana i'm going
to go with adasanya just because
i mean i i think honestly i i mean
blockovich definitely has power bro like
that's different
and arasanya is going up a weight class
he's going up a weight class to 205.
so what can happen when you go up a
weight class what what are some things
that can happen
not even specifically to them but what
are some things that could be
good or bad uh i mean the bigger animal
it's like the law of nature the bigger
animal usually beats the
the littler animal um but i think uh
so that's kind of a little bit of a
natural kind of pitfall yeah i mean
there's weight classes for a reason like
uh
if someone has 30 pounds on me and
they're
you know not nearly as good as me you
know they have a better chance against
someone who's my weight for sure you
know just because they're bigger you
know right they could lay on you and
hold you down yeah and it's harder to
move them like i think that there's two
types of strength
in jiu jitsu this might help you a
little bit too but there's
the type of strength where i can move
you really easy and then there's the
type of strength where
i make it so you can't move me very easy
there's those two types of strength and
um at my weight i can move people you
know
but if someone's 30 pounds heavier than
me like it's i
you know i can't move them as easy and
like that makes things a little bit
harder so yeah yeah so that's one thing
but
uh i think i think that that dude
has different level of power that i
think
israel is not dumb enough to
overlook you know i think that israel is
like a super smart dude and i don't
think he i don't think he's gonna leave
any stone unturned or like lie to
himself in his head like i see people do
that all the time in fighting just
because i
like going back to the ego stuff like
i'll see them say some stuff where i'm
just like
you're only saying that because it helps
you sleep at night you know like oh this
guy's slow or oh this guy can't grapple
it's like
man you're only saying that so you can
feel a little bit better about yourself
right and i noticed that right away you
know
uh israel i don't notice that in you
know where israel doesn't
he's not like oh this guy is slow it's
like or no he doesn't have power he like
acknowledges
the strengths in the other person and i
think that that's a really
obvious sign that like the person is
intelligent
you know i think it's really
unintelligent to just overlook
everything
that you're that your opponent has that
they do well yeah and just create an
excuse for it yeah but i think israel's
smart enough man and i think he has
enough experience and i'm sure that he's
had plenty of fights
in kickboxing where he's fought really
big dudes too that like we have never
even heard of because the dude has like
a million kickboxing fights
especially in new zealand yeah everybody
there is a pretty big dude yeah bro
hooker used to fight out like
heavyweighters is he really yeah
oh i used to train with hooker bro he
like demoralized me
did you yeah when he's funny isn't he
yeah he's funny
he used to uh like humorous i'm not
saying then hooker that you're there's
anything wrong with you
you're funny i just mean he's an
entertaining guy yeah
yeah yeah he used to uh he's actually a
really quiet guy i think in person
yeah yeah he's i'm a fan yeah yeah when
he used to train with us or whatever
uh dude he would whoop me bro really
why were you guys you guys sparring for
fun no he was like on he was like
training with our team and stuff oh but
not the same weight
i was a 45 back then and he was a 45
back then bro
yeah and i was like that's why it
demoralized me is because i was like
dude i'm never going to be
able to fight these guys dude
what are you
kidding me it's like it's like i got to
be a 25er to beat these guys if they're
going to be this size wearing you like a
backpack he's putting pencils and pins
in your pants
he's putting his school books in
there they used to tell me though like
hooker was never used to break his diet
i don't i mean i'm sure at 55 it's maybe
a little bit different but
yeah some guys on the team that like
knew him a little bit better would be
like yeah man like he never breaks his
diet and i was like wow
man he needs to go up so i can feel
a little better about myself man and so
that's when you were at 145.
yeah i used to my debut was at 45
because i didn't want to i know how the
ufc works like
you get a short notice call and that's
how you get into the ufc like very
rarely do guys
ever get into the ufc by you know like
hey
here's an eight-week camp and here's
your first date in the ufc that's not
how it works but like someone pulls out
and then and then so actually i fought
in phoenix
a week before my ufc debut so i fought
on a friday and then i i won that fight
as i'm taking off my hand wraps
uh someone from the commission is like
hey man like
ufc is on the phone they're like hey can
you fight next week and i'm like
i guess i'm not partying tonight but
yeah i mean i'll definitely
you know i'll definitely do that was
that an exciting call to get oh dude it
was so exciting man
so exciting like uh is that like the
best was that like the call
it was the call bro it was a call and
like uh
yeah bro for whatever reason man like uh
i get really pumped like knowing that i
made my loved ones like really proud
yeah you know uh and i remember like
it's one of my favorite parts like when
i do the visualizations i do a lot of
visualizations of like what happens
after the fight too because it really
motivates me you know and it makes me
feel nice like i'll imagine like face
time in my family
and my girlfriend and you know and like
you know they're super pumped for me and
stuff so
that's what that was for me is it was i
remember i was on the phone with my
sister and for what it for whatever
reason like
it was my sister but i was i like called
my sister and i was like hey like i did
it like they want me
you know next week and then i was like
yeah and then i remember talking to
christian and i was like
i was like watching his film because i
was like it if i get a contract i
don't care how tough the guy is i don't
care if he beats my ass as long as i get
a contract and i watch the guy this is
when you know my confidence wasn't like
where it is now
and i was like oh i think i'm
really going to beat this guy like it
was like some surprise you know
christian was like
yeah dude what like they're calling you
for a reason dumb ass like
oh so you think they called you think
they thought you would beat the guy
i don't know if they did or not but that
dude fought on the contender series
uh and they just needed like a
replacement fight like they have to put
a certain amount of fights
to fill their tv slot or whatever and
yeah that's how you get signed to the
ufc pretty much is like some short
notice like that
yeah it was cool dude i remember i
remember the time i got a text from joe
rogan to come be on his podcast
and that was that was that for me nice
it was like the best thing
like out of sure and being like what
what am i gonna do i brought him a bag
of oranges dude i didn't know what to do
people said he likes like diet or
something so i got a bag
diet so i bought him like a um
bag of clementines and brought him over
there
i showed up in a bag how'd it go
it went fine was it scary it was so
scary
it was like dude honestly i think going
in that would almost be like going and
being in a
in a fight man yeah it was so scary were
you like
were you more like uh were you like
don't this up type of
i was just scared it was like um
i knew other people that had been on it
like famous people
educators like that yeah really
yeah uh i don't know joe doesn't care if
you like
say that you're gonna be on the show
either right uh-uh yeah i'm going on a
show
last week yeah no way bro bro so i got a
text from him and or
an instagram message i know bro and it
was it just came randomly from him
yeah yeah wow and i don't know what i'm
talking about yeah dude
i was like yes you text me you know like
i was super pumped but i was like
uh in my head though i'm just like yeah
man there's like
real legit people you know yeah like
smart
you know like legit people that are like
that foes on there
alien on their last week yeah they're
like changing the world and
yeah i'll be honest i just had a sip of
diet coke
and i'll also be honest that i have
mental health issues and
you know it's we're all fighting
something and sometimes we're fighting
demons from the past
better help that's right better
help is here to help you
if something is interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you
with a licensed professional therapist
that's what they do
there's a broad range of expertise
available you can do it on the phone
over text
over uh facetime they're committed
to getting great therapeutic matches
it's easy and free to change counselors
if you need to
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com theo join the over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
theo you need help get help look you
want to look good right you want your
body to look nice and as a man it's hard
it's hard to get your body your body's
lumpy you got a lump in the front that
ween
it's hard to get tight your shoulders
around you don't know what the hell is
going on
well fabletics men
represents for every guy who wants to
look and feel his best without
breaking the bank you can't spend
two million on a chiffon shirt
keep it simple that means lululemon
quality for half the price
because they know guys deserve nothing
less than the best gear
on the market go to fabletics.com
theo for access to an insane deal
get your first two pairs of shorts for
just
four dollars that's right twelve dollars
a pair
when you become a fabletics men vip
member at checkout all styles all
colors no exclusions it's an insane deal
because they know that once you try
their gear you will be
hooked to get the best activewear at the
best
prices get at least 20 to 50 off retail
prices
every time you shop fabletics
fabulous men get free shipping on all
orders over 49
free returns and exchanges within 45
days
we're talking top quality at half the
price each month
vip members can choose to be billed
49.95 for a member credit
members can use that credit toward any
item
or kit up to 80 dollars that's right get
billed 49.95
get a credit that costs something up to
80 or you can skip the month and pay
nothing
there's no limit to how many times you
can skip that's right go to
fabletics.com
theo for the insane deal
that's awesome man um yeah dude it was
so much fun
and then also i think for you to be able
to go in there and talk to a guy like
that just knows so much about like what
you guys
do and um yeah that's awesome
yeah i think i was just i i'm
intimidated by joe
as a person and it's nothing he does
it's just who kind of who i am and where
i kind of come into hum
like relationships at it sometimes i
think but um
so i think i was probably kind of
nervous about that maybe
um what else do you still feel that way
like even if i went back or you still
yeah
i think some things make me feel a
little bit
it was live then also oh yeah live
feels very nervous you know like i wish
you guys at least
that's what i feel bad for you guys like
tim this is live like if you
hit you can't ask him to edit it
like hey can you just edit this so it
just looks like a square dance between
two people
um that's but uh that's awesome man
i feel like in like being alive that's
like the call to get
like getting to go there and you get to
go to austin too yeah and see the new
place that's
yeah yeah yeah dude that's so cool yeah
i mean i don't really you know i
i don't i don't see myself as someone
that's like
uh you know i i don't know if this is
the advice that i would give
every fighter or whatever um but like
man i remind myself all the time how
much i suck at
this right like i remind myself that all
the time so like
when when you messaged me and was like
hey can i come on your i was like pumped
because like to me
in my head still i think because of the
you know what helps me
survive is that like i still don't think
i'm like
any good yeah you know like i know that
i'm good comparatively to everyone else
but i still don't feel like i'm like
good right because i understand like
what
good actually means in my brain and so
like when i get a text from you or like
joe or whatever and
that happens and i was like oh dude
i don't really think i'm good enough for
that
right but yeah maybe there's probably
some of that when i'm thinking back on
that i'm trying to think if i had some
of that
yeah i think well it's also interesting
because a lot of the
a lot of life is bandwagon a lot of
people are bandwagon as much as we don't
want to think that we
are or that other like
you know it's like but also some of it
is you have to get
it's so hard to get people's attention
yeah so it's not like that people didn't
care
a lot of times it's like people's
attention is divided by a million
so to get five percent of that for you
know for a day or whatever it's like
it's just hard to get people to see you
in the world because there's so many
people
yeah yeah um but dang that's awesome
though dude that's really cool
just because yeah joe introduced
actually
the first fighter i ever met i think was
from joe and it was al jamaine sterling
at the comedy store nice
nice and i remember thinking that this
guy's a fighter yeah not thinking that
he wasn't you always think fighters of
like you know these big like
from 300 or something and then they're
just kind of like um
in stature from sight he seemed like a
totally normal nice guy yeah yeah when
uh so i used to go to alpha male a
little bit
you know team alpha male 1 like where
garbrandt faber all of those dudes
oh yeah faber uh dilla shaw used to
train there uh
benavidez used to train there so like
some really good names so anyways
the heaviest handshake dude you try to
shake his hand who favors you better
work for logging yeah
the dude is a guy my god bro
it's like you had four hands in each
hand
i was like how many hands do you have
dude uh
dude so i went out to there because for
whatever reason on our team it's like a
bunch of tall lanky guys like we don't
have that build where it's like short
stocky strong guys
so i go out i i wasn't even a
professional yet i had just
gone out to help de la shaw train for uh
his fight against bural
yeah i was still an amateur actually
back then but um i go out to help him
bro and i like get there
and everyone's this tall bro i was like
i was like what is going on like because
the cage so bro the cage at
the cage at most of our gyms are like
six feet high
you know but the ufc cage must be like
five foot
eight or something whatever it is so
like when i walk into the ufc cage i
feel like a monster
you know because i can yeah because i'm
on tv that we see yeah yeah cause i can
kind of like look over the cage a little
bit
you know but the cages that we all use
to train in are much higher
so like i thought that all of those
people were like the size of that cage
you know yeah so when i got there i was
like
all these little guys jumping rope like
you know i was like what are these guys
you know yeah yeah yeah that's funny but
yeah the ufc cage is actually pretty
cool because
that's like a squad right there yeah oh
damn yeah dude
yeah it's like minuto this is like a
latino boy
no offense either uh no just everyone's
jacked yeah yeah yeah it was funny
it was funny my first time out i was
like so dillashaw's in y'all's weight
division
yeah he's a 35 and what about henry
cejudo he is
he's yeah he won the 35 belt and he's
gone what happened to him he went to
fight where he went to another
planet or something where is he he
retired on another planet i think he's
retired i think he wants a lot of money
man
oh really yeah yeah yeah well dana
doesn't pay those man bro
no that's the facts dude yeah you got to
be you know you got to be a mcgregor
i think to get the money that he's
asking for
wow but but at a certain level you got
to decide yeah is this is it worth me
doing this again
yeah but you also know what's cool in
mma too is that like
cejudo could come back in a couple years
yeah like that's a real thing
yeah like that what sport is like that
you know where it's just like yeah i'm
me i'm back yeah you know guess what
yeah like jerry aikman just comes back
and you put him in a game
no that's really true
yeah there's no other sport like that
yeah and it's been fascinating that
during this pandemic that
that they were able you guys were able
to get it done i mean it's really
because it's like
the sport has progressed so much so many
new eyes on the sport
i mean the amount of like followers and
um supporters that people are getting
now i mean it's
huge and it's allowing and i feel like
this is
one of the ways that god even this
things out is that
a lot of guys not getting paid fairly
via the organization and you don't have
to agree with that that's my own
summation of it and i'm just a fan and i
don't know very much
but now a lot of them are able to do
other marketing things and do other
things
um where they're able to make some extra
money because their followings are also
getting so big
sure sure so that's really like such a
blessing for those guys you know
because to go out there and put your i
mean a guy comes out of
one eye you know it's like yeah and he's
got eleven
thousand dollars yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you're right you know um dude
if i wasn't able to fight in the last
year because ufc had to shut down
i don't know what i would do man i would
be half crazy bro what would you have
done what's the job you would have gone
into and we'll pull that question up
right now is this
it nick boom this question's for corey
but theo you can answer it too if you
want
um i was wondering what would you do
as an occupation if you weren't an mma
fighter for the ufc
thanks gang gang gang bro so that would
have been it man what would you have
done you think in this time if
would have gone away you gotta
do something i mean i i told you i was
working at that uh oh the
residential treatment facility yeah so i
was working there
i mean i probably would still be doing
that you know like uh
before the ufc when i was actually
getting paid like um
i was doing that bro like overnights
saturday sundays
wow uh i was working twelves you know
i'm not going to say it was like i was
growing in a 60-hour week you know like
it was probably like 20 to 25 hours a
week but that was on top of maybe like
20 25 hours of training and then like
another probably
10 or 15 hours of like holding mitts for
people and trying to make money that way
too so
i'd probably be doing something in
social work as my guess you know like uh
that like kids bro i'd much rather have
a conversation with a kid than i would
like an adult any day of the week like i
just get along with them better i i
think that they have more
you know advice that maybe is a little
bit better than a lot of the
adults advice you know and i i like
learning from kids man like that's uh
that's my second thing in life you know
it's fighting and then it's probably you
know
just hanging out with kids in any type
of
setting i think when i was 16 even i
used to work at this daycare center um
i would i would leave high school boom
go to there it was at the elementary
school that i was with i would work
there till six and i was doing that five
days a week
and then and then i went off to college
and then right after college i went and
got that
treatment facility gig and then uh yeah
so i've been around kids i'm teaching
the kids program at high altitude
martial arts oh really
yup dude that's dope bro yeah man i just
like hanging out so
they must be so psyched for you they
only started giving me respect when i
got into the video game bro oh they
don't leave yeah
video game now yeah yeah that's what uh
that's bro all of them come up to me
they don't know it you know like they're
like they watch my fights now but before
it was just like
you fighting john cena when you find
john cena i'm like
shut up and then now and they wouldn't
you know like they would listen but they
wouldn't really listen and now that i'm
in a game
and now they all chirp to each other
that i'm in a video game like now it's
like you know i got some juice
yeah now i get a virtual man
he's got a hologram dude that uh it
brings you up to those top notch have
you seen those basketball cards that are
out now oh yeah yeah
you see this uh let's bring this up top
notch
so there's a new so we grew up
collecting the regular cards christian
i'm sure you probably did too man
collecting some type of a card baseball
basketball football
now the cards are virtual it's a top
shot
top shop oh bro i heard of uh i heard
that they're doing like virtual art also
where you can earn
or buy virtual art really
i think so i i i sometimes just make
stuff up though i
i would believe something like that i
mean this is you get a card can you show
us what one of the cards is nick yeah
this is it right here so just an example
you can get a tyler harrow
stop shot and it's basically just a play
you own
they have a limited number of these that
they make
and if you get that in your pack then
you get that you buy it like a pack of
cards for a certain amount of money you
open it up it has a certain number of
these in it
and instead of just an image of them
doing something you have a video
of them doing something so you could
eventually at some point you could have
a top shot
how do you feel about this you know i
will admit that i set an alarm this
morning to get up and buy some and slept
through it
or you gotta wake up to get them well
yeah they only release it at 9am that's
what they're doing right now so
i think that's where i'm at with it i'm
curious but i'm also
willing to continue to get some rest
and he's eventually going to lose five
dollars you still watch basketball yeah
uh i don't watch basketball anymore no i
mean i it got away from me i think
it was one of the sports i got away from
me during the pandemic even before that
i wasn't that into it
so what are you buying then um that's a
good point i would just be buying
just for the novelty oh yeah that's what
i would do is just for the novelty
yeah i think yeah during this pandemic i
got a lot more into watching you guys's
sport
it's weird now right to not have a fight
on a saturday
like i don't know when that happened but
like for me at least in my life like
it's like oh there's no fight this
saturday
like that's like oh yeah it's like a
weekly yeah thing
a little bit yeah yeah from end of
december to like
um january 22nd yeah
it was three saturdays it was
horrible yeah it was weird right
and there's like little things that are
just kind of funny like i'll remember
every time he fights i'll remember that
it's a glow over to cher not glover
and that always blows my mind
just like little things that kind of
keep me excited about the sport you know
um but it's fun to like see guys and
then go back and watch their old fights
and just kind of learn like just some of
the history of what goes on
it's fun to go to classes and then like
um
and like kind of get to have a better
idea of like why people are kind of
doing little things
in the inside of y'all's ring um
the punches part still kind of really
spooks me out
but the uh yeah it just makes me a
little nervous you know
yeah yeah i just don't know if i'm ready
for that but i think part of me wants
eventually to get out there and really
just get beat up you know
and just go through that you
know yeah because i think there's
something
there's a more unique me on the other
side of that
yeah and so you know that's yeah like
i think uh some of that's kind of
intriguing to me and it's funny because
that
three four five years ago that never
would have been something would come out
of my mouth so it's interesting to see
an effect like somebody like joe rogan
has had an effect on so many comedians
of wanting to learn about
um mixed martial arts and just
bringing eyeballs to it and then also i
think it helps with a lot of trauma i
think it helps
people get rid of like just deep rooted
like uncomfort and anger
it makes me realize that i can interact
with another man
and be okay i'm not gonna like i can
fight technically fight but still also
be okay
and there's gonna be a level of respect
which i think when i was growing up
nobody was teaching me any kind of
lesson of like
you know you can hit somebody or hit
them they can hit you back and you can
still
then be fr you know there was nobody was
teaching me any level of
human interaction that had to do with or
or how to manage any kind of
anger so i just think as an adult it's
like
it kind of sucks because i'm having to
learn like a lot of like stuff from
childhood
late in life but that's that there's
nothing i can do about that that's just
my life
and um but i do think it's fascinating
how
going and getting on the mats and like
there's a level of camaraderie
there's a level of tough guys that
accept you whereas when you're growing
up the tough guys are always like
it's the that's the bully that's the guy
you're afraid to be around or at least
you think you are
you know so i think there's so many
little levels of like um
helpful human interaction that go along
with it
um that's fascinating that's why i think
it's fascinating that the childhood
trauma i bet that
that kind of stuff can probably be so
helpful to those kids yeah yeah
yep i mean i i don't do any of that with
the kids but yeah man i think
i mean it's interesting to listen to
talk because i think everyone does it
for like a different reason
you know i think that that's part of
like the really cool part is that
there could be a number of different
things and different paths or whatever
and like like you said man it's like uh
it can help with like a lot of things
and like there's a level of camaraderie
to it and
yeah all of that good stuff man it's
good i think bro and like
you watch any animal like they're all
doing it they're all little when they're
puppies bro they're all fighting each
other like puppies fight each other
little baby
any are always like wrestling and
fighting each other you know yeah
and we take our kids and let
them just sit there and eat cookies
fight these even little
kids though even little kids if you put
two little kids in a room together
and you leave nothing else in there
they'll probably start wrestling each
other you know
we need a encouragement dude
it's inside of everyone bro like that's
a
i'm a big believer of like us bro we're
just an
animal species that is like this much
smarter than all the other animal
species bro
but we're still that animal species and
like we still
do like we still want more like we still
want to take territory just like every
other animal we still want to
gather more resources and more food just
like every other animal
you know and we still want to fight just
yeah dude it's weird too i don't know
you you said you haven't started
uh like punching and stuff no no no no
so yeah so i got an
irv over there is a coach that that that
teaches that so so let me know
after you do that how i feel well i just
want to know if you're able to hit
someone
okay because i have a lot of people that
i coach where they're like man like it's
so weird to like
it's like i don't want to hit someone
you know it's like weird for me to hit
someone and i'm like yeah because we
were told not to do it our whole lives
you're told not to hit someone your
entire life like it's not going to feel
normal to like
throw have you ever had a dream like
that where you go to punch someone in a
dream and you
just want to tell you that you can't do
it yeah everybody has that dream i've
had a million dreams where i can't even
i can literally get my fist to right
here and it won't
yeah go anymore i've had it i've had it
probably 200 times
it's weird huh and it's weird yeah and i
i'll feel like i'm trying it again and
it will not do it
it's weird man and there's some like
it's like a wall that's like connected
to like my
feeling i don't know what it is but
there's some that's crazy you said yeah
yeah yeah i think everyone has that
dream
or at least i a lot of people that i've
talked to at least at the gym and it's
like
yeah because we're told not to do this
or maybe we're like innately really nice
creatures and we don't want to hurt
people
but also i think that it's like we're
told not to do it our whole lives
like it's weird hitting someone man like
it's weird yeah
yeah i think it'd be interesting man
i'll i'll have to update you dude yeah
um but i'm trying to think if we covered
everything nick
yeah i think so i did actually uh did
you plant
you probably planned the knee because
like everybody's saying like
frankie pops his head when he's like go
on sorry did you did you plan the wheel
kick was that something you guys talked
about or did you just do that in the
moment against maurice yeah that was
just in the moment
uh everything was kind of just in the
moment uh with
uh yeah it's a lot of not thinking and
just letting like the
the system play out i i think a little
bit with frankie is
there was maybe a little bit more like
quick thinking going on where i
i didn't know how what he was gonna do
when we were fighting like i knew that
he'd be eager to wrestle because
everyone
likely thinks that my wrestling is
terrible just based off of
you know my my fight with sterling which
is really the only wrestling
in exchange that i've had in the ufc so
i i thought he'd be a little bit quick
to wrestle and then he threw like a
couple combinations and i was like oh
this guy you know he
he's gonna you know at least throw a few
punches and then i threw i threw the
kick
and i heard his corner say uh
that's it frankie that's it like and he
was excited that he got out of the way
of something that i threw
you know because not that and i don't
mean to sound arrogant but if i'm
frankie fighting me
after i beat maurice that way and just
based off of my other performances
i'm probably a little bit you know maybe
not the most confident guy in the world
uh being that frankie got knocked out a
couple times before his fight with munoz
or whatever so
anyways when when i heard
his coach praised him for him missing
i saw like a little bit of spunk in him
you know and i was like ah he's either
gonna try to shoot or he's gonna try to
attack again and then
uh because that's a reaction when people
get a little bit of heightened energy
one of the first reactions is to then do
something yeah yeah he's like oh i'm
doing good and then
and then and i noticed every time he got
close to me he was
he was trying to do something you know
he was trying to hit i think he kicked
me one time too but
there was no like there was no
uh playing there or seeing what i was
gonna do it was just like hey when we
get close enough to this guy try to hit
him and like
he did that twice and then i was like
okay he's probably gonna do it a third
time and that's when that's when i threw
that
because you thrown it against marias but
it didn't land right i've thrown it a
number of times
you know because i mean i fight everyone
that's shorter than me so like it'd be
stupid for me not to
oh yeah you know throw something it's
really just like an uppercut with your
leg
yeah pretty much yeah uppercut with your
leg but um damn man
yeah yeah oh so that's how that looked
dramatic
yeah it was delicious yeah it was nasty
jesus christ
still makes me sad bro
[Laughter]
i mean i think yeah maybe that's why i
can't punch people i think that just
makes me sad is it hard for christian to
keep challenging you i know your coach
is here someone i want to give you one
question about him is it hard for him to
keep challenging you like
what do you guys do like what is what's
kind of different um
about as you evolve as a fighter and as
you kind of put some wins together what
is
what does coaching look like is it
harder for you to learn do you feel like
less of a pupil
any any any of those questions laying
with you yeah i think it's a little bit
more cooperative
in the way that we work together it's
more of like a
interaction opposed to him telling me
what to do but it was never really like
that in any ways
i will say like uh christian's really
interesting guy
you know and uh i think that uh he lives
by his own set of rules
he's like a super uh don't think
just don't think you know he's very
radical in the idea of like
just be present and don't think and i
think that that makes him
super super creative and i think that it
makes it so that he doesn't view things
in a way that
is old or is uh
damaged by any other way of doing things
you know it'd be like
it'd be like if you went out and did a
comedy stand-up and hadn't watched any
stand-up before and you just tried to
make people laugh
like i feel like that's how he
approaches a lot of things and obviously
that's more or less impossible no but
that's kind of fascinating
yeah but that's how he looks at stuff so
like man like i'm
totally grateful like i said man he's
one of my best friends
i you know like he's taught me how to be
the way that i am and to view things in
the exact same way
and uh i've worked with like a lot of
coaches and i mean he's
you know he's the most creative guy in
martial arts that i've ever met
it's interesting and it really fits your
style i think in your sense of
capabilities you know
um even sugar sean's kind of that same
way you guys are both such kind of
malleable
capable almost like cool to see on a
video game type of patterns because you
have moves that are kind of
a little bit unorthodox or unique or
rare
yeah um like when i watch your fights
i'm always like i wonder what
if there's going to be something new
that i'll see out of him that i haven't
seen before
and that's kind of interesting because
you don't always think that about
different fighters you know
yeah um that's good man because every
time i want to look different bro like i
was actually really excited in the last
one to show off a bunch of the wrestling
and grappling stuff that i had been
working
because it's really cool like it's
really really cool like some of the
stuff that i've
uh i don't know how much he wants me to
say his name or whatever but ryan hall
do you know who ryan hall is
i know kyle hall but i don't think
they're
this a different this is i mean
obviously it's a different guy but i
don't know
so ryan also fights in the ufc he hasn't
fought in a couple years but
uh man some of the grappling stuff that
i'm doing with him
is just so cool bro and like uh
i think it's gonna be super exciting
when i actually get to do it against
like hopefully for
a world title you know like i'm pumped
for that is it kind of disappointing
sometimes because you guys have all
these plans you go into the fight and
then sometimes the fight in so quick
you're like dude
we didn't get to do that never dude
really never no no no any bro
any time it can go like how it went last
time dude signing up for that every
single
time dude every single time yeah i guess
because i would always be
like damn dude we didn't get to do any
of the freaking headlocks you know
that's how i feel like that would be but
yeah maybe you're right dude
maybe you're right man um corey sanegan
man bro thank you so much for coming in
dude and for just letting somebody who
doesn't know much about
fighting just kind of freely talk about
you guys as sport you know and not like
uh you know it's just nice to be able to
you know
if i get things wrong or not get them
right or something to not like
feel like um you know uh being
disrespectful to what you guys do
you know because it's hard to learn and
talk about things at the same time
um but it's exciting man so thank you
guys congrats on all your success bro
thanks man yeah excited to keep watching
it dude yeah yeah cool thank you yeah
thanks a lot for having me on bro you
bet man
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel
i'm falling like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my eye
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy
[Music]
now